hello everybody and welcome to part 3 of
let's play from dust
now we left off we just kick the ass of
a gigantic wave like it was nothing
in fact it was nothing all right gotta
get my guys over to this totem before
that timer runs out I imagine cuz yeah
what it does
buttload of water and no protection so
let's get the guys moving go go get all
bhai
don't worry I'll build the bridges stop
ye water go another way
oh it's build another it's gonna be
little harder to stop than I thought
get don't break my bridge come here
oh yeah you got nothing against me oh
I'm the bit oh don't even try it don't
even try it
yep yep I stopped at dam at good done
darn
alright a little more a little more a
little more
I'm sure I'm pretty sure why that that's
why that whole hill is there in the
first place just so that I can build
this okay all right come on go down the
other way gosh goodness gracious
germinate Christmas
all right little more I'm gonna keep
trying guys but you better hurry cause
this it's don't last this does not last
you think it is some fragile building
material like sand or something oh no
I'll save you oh yeah oh uh who's a hero
huh me I'll help you I'll help you I'm
sorry about that whole destroying your
village last last levels thing alright
come on
okay I got you I got you okay keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going okay god dammit alright okay sorry
if I just buried any of you in sand more
bar bar bar or okay oh come on it's just
a small you can cross a little water
it's not that big a deal
oh oh maybe I should have done it down
there I'm probably stupid alright anyway
ah running out of time oh this is
killing me
it's literally just the water the
physics are so good at it roads away
everything I put up I just got to be
fast
all right faster faster faster okay well
I don't have time I'm trying to help you
trying to help you right now
okay here we go here we go here we go a
little more a little more almost got it
almost got it guys bear with me bear
with me bear with me oh oh yeah oh yeah
I got it oh oh lucky ain't no thang look
at that look at that damn I just built
oh I am good and that is pretty ah
that's pretty pretty alright you need
one more guy where's where's the last
one where's the last one come on waiting
on you buddy oh where are you come on
let's get going let's get going
oh that's right yeah build it build it
up build it
and then repopulate don't worry I won't
watch okay open up a passageway all
right I can move on to the next area
but I'm not quite ready yet I think
there are still some other things on
this island now I'm gonna find him all
right
oh yeah oh this is huge
oh wow this is very big okay um Wow
as big the level of scale that they've
got all the way out here I think the
world view world view and then all the
way down to the individual person and
that person is very detailed really
really they are is awesome
all right I'm sure I'll find something
to complain about soon but for now I'm a
bridge
oh come on come on now you've got the
secret of repelling water I gotta I
gotta stop all of his water so that you
can repel it
all right that sound pulling up the sand
sounds exactly like pulling wood from
black and white yep okay
I think he's protecting that village now
all right cool
both my villages are protected from
water oh but that a poor sucker if he's
out there when the tsunami comes I feel
bad for I don't know what's going on
there but put some dirt more vegetation
I'm going to try to get 100% vegetation
again uh-oh I got to connect the I gotta
connect the landmasses so that the
vegetation can spread as far as I know
it only spreads
don't ask me how it grows on Sam but it
does okay
all right oh this is gonna be hard okay
swing long oh man this is gonna be hard
because that's a huge river that I got
to stop as a huge river but I can do it
ain't nothing I can't do good over there
fill it up to the top oh oh who's the
best Oh who's the best all right
that's why they worship me and that's
why you guys all watch my videos
actually it's pretty fun I'm celebrating
a simple task building bridges if I
could literally save the entire planet
but that's how I am
all right vegetation go go go go
okay I didn't see any of those memory
stone doohickeys I don't think there are
any around oh what's that
that's just a rock ah nothing there
nothing there nothing there oh oh oh oh
tsunami Oh bring it on both my villages
are ready oh oh what's that oh that
doesn't look so bad Oh only only two
hundred feet tall bull honkey get out of
here
watch this oh what's this oh oh what oh
oh nothing oh yeah yeah here I'll soak
up some water while you're at it I'll
help
I'm helping guys
I hope you're grateful of the help I'm
doing oh it's washing away all my
bridges isn't it oh no I just built the
bridge damn it no my bridge this Oh
gotta save it save it no got to build it
100 feet high before they get there I
have time I have time I have time I've
time oh oh oh oh man oh oh darn it my
hard work yeah whatever whatever
good job other village look at you go
you would have been fine anyway though
by the looks of it all this dam still
held up that's good to know
maybe this will still be here when it's
done alright alright okay just a little
segment that got broken no big deal NBD
now I got to get them space to go to
this this thing pick up some water and
good somewhere else
all right okay all right here we go
um
oh ah I could divert the flow oh I can
never add the flow oh so smart mark oh
you're so smart
come on get more I know you can give
more than that all right whatever divert
the flow of water down here oh yeah look
at that oh look at that it's like I'm
smart or something oh gosh that's right
oh this is cool okay cool
migrating animals don't know how they
got there but whatever whatever gone I
absolutely sure that there was nothing
else was this whoa what is this
something too much soil can block it the
water carries varying around soil isn't
deposits in downstream oh okay okay so I
can block these things but they also
carry soil downstream oh wow that's
awesome that's how the deltas are
automatically form themselves oh wait
cool all right I like it I like it a lot
all right let's get going go but it
actually wait how do I cancel that exit
it's almost time for me to change over
so I'm gonna just so apparently I'm
guessing these are those migrating
animals oh man if I saw those things in
real life I would want them dead because
those are like those sea creatures you
see horsey horseshoes horseshoe crabs
see horseshoes Oh anyway horseshoe crabs
but giganto oh yeah they're as big as
elephants man all right well that's all
the time I have for now thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoy it
I will see you guys in part 4 of let's
play from dust bye bye